[Music]
neon lights are making America a little
brighter again it's been nearly 100
years since his country's first neon
sign was imported from France this
spring and summer exhibits featuring
neon will light up museums galleries and
Botanical Gardens across the United
States a new generation of neon lovers
is crafting this Renaissance
mark Strassmann went to Austin Texas to
meet the man responsible for 300 of that
city's iconic signs it doesn't really
advertise the brand it's getting closer
to art than it is to signage what evan
Voyles calls doodling in light has lit
up the Austin skyline what I'm known for
is South Congress and this is where
South Congress starts this is your turf
this is my turf and so this is saying
you know welcome the 58 year old
designed this fish riding cowboy for
Yeti the popular cooler company
that was the first one I put up on this
trip on South Congress Avenue here his
canvass of neon runs four blocks that
was the first outdoor commercial sign
ever built and when I finished it and we
had on the wall we lit it up I jumped up
and down I was amazed it looks so great
I couldn't believe I'd done it it was
like pulling off a magic trick I didn't
know how to do since then his hometown
skyline has taken on a growing blow so
look this is art but it's art that as a
job to do is gonna get people in the
store its primary job is to communicate
an idea form an impression in your head
that will make you go into the store if
I don't get people in then I have failed
as American folk art neon found its
heyday in the 30s 40s and 50s a
landscape of colorful lights stretched
across the country but when cheaper
plastic and LED signs came along neon
fizzle until recently people have always
loved the American roadside and the
attraction of that glowing neon sign in
the distance
neon historian Eric links Wyler wrote a
book about its glory days neon is
definitely making a comeback right now
every neon artist and the unbend er that
I know in Southern California is working
more now than they have in the past few
decades
throughout the US new and newly restored
neon signs now light up businesses
stadiums and hotels along with art
galleries and museums I think that neon
is definitely representing a retro
Americana that people are embracing but
it's also a technology that people
haven't seen for a while and they're
falling in love with it yet again but
the technology has barely changed in
over a century I find it a great irony
that in this day and age I am
essentially building something from the
age of buggies but to me it's like I am
bringing you the past I am tying you to
something you don't even think about
Voyles designs the signs blueprint but
bending neon tubes is a special skill
kirk and rory tunning li own Big Dawg
neon in Lockhart Texas how long did it
take you to like figure it out in weeks
I was producing tubes that functioned
but to make good-looking tubes probably
took a year and a half it's a feel that
comes from experience the glass tube
between the fingers the slow and steady
breath control that keeps the tube from
collapsing in on itself as its heated up
to 1,200 degrees and then bent the red
yes is pure neon pure neon yes yep once
the glass takes shape gas is pumped in
most signs today are actually filled
with argon gas which is more versatile
but the iconic vivid red color is all
Nia so to you what is the romance of Nia
to me it's it's step that line drawing
with light and color and that there's no
better way to do that yet I just don't
think they're going to invent it on a
lifetime Boyle's has brought this city a
new globe with his take on the blurry
line between art and commerce
for CBS this morning mark Strassmann
Austin Texas
[Music]